hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the tip of the iceberg
how pipette tips influence assay results
I am too fan of leverage and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by eppendorf Eppendorf is a
leading life science company that
develops themselves instruments
consumables and services for liquid
sample and cell handling in laboratories
worldwide for more information please
visit Eppendorf comm we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the live event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
green Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems meeting or hearing those
presentations please click on the
support button at the top right
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the TV button
located on the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would like
now to introduce today's speaker dr.
Ulrich as guest dr. guest specializes in
applications for liquid handling systems
competing customers for their correct
use she has supported several Eppendorf
pipette calibration services worldwide
in their credit evasion process within
the frame of development of the new
guideline which is the dkg are 8-1 she
was a member of the responsive
international Technical Committee of CJD
an official body for calibration
solutions the guideline defines
technical requirements for the
calibration of liquid handling systems
and the set up of measurement and
certainty budget for calibration lab dr.
gas will impede
gee and biology from the University of
Jim can based on a broad spectrum of
methods she has a great deal of
practical experience in both the correct
use of liquid handling systems in their
performance testing I will now turn it
over to not to gasps another
presentation Thanks soon for the nice
introduction and hello hello and the
warm welcome to everybody from Hamburg
in Germany within today's educators
webinar I would like to explain how tips
can influence pipetting results our
agenda looks as follows I'm starting
with a short introduction into a widely
unknown problem you might face in your
lab we are then approaching the context
by checking out the iOS 655 the standard
for liquid handling after this I am
presenting some results of a broad study
we have performed this webinar will
probably bring up some question marks
regarding the use of piper tips thus I
do not want to end the webinar without
giving recommendations before I finish
with a summary there is some time for
the questions at the end of this webinar
if you know before I before we start now
I would like to make a quick poll and
ask you are you familiar with the topic
of piper tip related influences
okay so the results you can see on the
screen now so we have 65% saying yes I'm
familiar with tip related influencing
factors and 35% roughly say no thank you
very much for your vote from time to
time Eppendorf gets calls for help like
this one
we recently tested the performance of
our pipers by calibration being a big
surprise we found a couple of them to be
out of specification but we send the
pipers to service for repair however the
service sent them back with the
information that they are working
correctly so what is the problem with my
pipers now I check the performance of
these pilots using the customer setup
the calibration result was the following
this is the measurement report of the
customer piped as you can see on the top
he is working with an Eppendorf research
plus 1000 microliters fixed volume piped
using a balance I performed 10
measurements and all environmental data
were ok our calculation also has been
proven to be correct as you probably
know the performance of a pipette is
determined by two errors this is the
Matic error or cause also called
inaccuracy and the random error or
imprecision called the random error now
in the middle block you can see the
measurement result as well as the
allowed error tolerances called limit
values well we see that in this case the
customer is right the inner courtesy is
exceeded it is roughly 4 times higher
than allowed
thereby the - indicates that not enough
volume has been aspirated and dispensed
into the balance so what is the problem
here
a little detail is mentioned below the
results box instead of Eppendorf tips
some other manufacturer tips have been
used if maybe from a generic tip
provider can this be the problem it
makes sense to test the piping private
again using the original Eppendorf tips
this protocol gives the result of
calibrating sign private in the same way
just a few minutes later the only
difference is the use of F and of tips
if you look into the middle block you
can see that now the inaccuracy is okay
is it magic no of course not but
obviously the alternative private tips
influence the pipetting result in a way
that the error limits become exceeded
accordingly to this finding the ISO a
six five five standard States private
and tip to be and system the iso at 6:55
deals with piston stroke pipettes
regarding the interaction of piped and
tips it stipulates the error limits are
relat for the whole system consisting of
piped and piper tip suppliers
declaration or certificate of Conformity
do not apply if the type of tips are
used which are not delivered by the
piped manufacturer for in order to find
out more about this context we performed
a large study including standard tips of
fifteen different manufacturers we
calibrated 10 mark liter and thousand
Mac relatives we have already seen that
tips can have an impact on the pipetting
result but the overall result of this
study was rather surprising
interestingly it was mainly let's say
extreme volumes
the error limit were exceeded one
microliter with Penmark negatives and
thousand microliter with thousand my
glitter tips for this reason here i show
the results of these two volumes the
imprecision is shown on the y-axis from
this axis and the systematic error or
inaccuracy is shown on the y-axis sorry
on the x-axis all data points within the
red area our calibration results within
the manufacturers pipette specifications
now with a burn octave the pipetting
system was within these error tolerances
in total the system failed the
calibration with aid of 15 tip
manufacturers the calibration the
calibration was repeated by a different
calibrating person at a different
calibration lab but using another
manufacturer pipette and guess what the
results confirmed our findings this
indicates that the findings are not
linked to a certain pipette there are
general influencing factors which evoke
these results but what are these tip
related influencing factors are all of
these tips of bad quality in
to solve this question let us start with
the peak volume here the thousand
microliter for understanding the main
influencing factor on bigger volumes we
need to understand that functional
principle of a piston stroke piped a
so-called air cutting pipette in between
the piston inside of the pipette and the
liquid service in the piper tip and air
currents exist this occasion can be
influenced by a number of factors on
this picture you can see an Eppendorf
thousand likely to tip as it was used
within the study on the right hand side
you can now see the alternative tips
that phase the calibration at thousand
michael inter just by visual comparison
you can easily see that the tips have
different sizes and different sizes mean
different volumes of air cousin
different shapes also lead to a
different liquid filling level both
factors the air crushing size and the
filling level have been reported by
literature to influence the inner policy
and this brings up to an important
section by the manufacturer pilots
become adjusted to a certain tip design
meaning they become adjusted to certain
air cutting size and liquid filling
level so if an alternative tip is used
the system may not work within allowed
error tolerances just because of the
tips design if we now look to the small
pipetting volume of one microliter we
are facing a completely different and
influencing factor we found tips of five
manufacturers to push the system out of
the error tolerances the air custom size
could not have be called could not not
have caused this
since the Eppendorf 10 mark leader tips
have been shown to be the biggest within
the study thus we had to search for
another influencing factor and hear the
feedback from a german customer brought
us on the right track the customer
complained problems with one of our
manual pipettes he found it impossible
to dispense very small volumes like 0.8
microliters onto a solid surface he
described that sometimes the drop was
created at the tips orifice and
sometimes not he was using alternative
tips so we gave him a sample of our
standard tips and he found the problem
to be solved so obviously the
influencing factor had something to do
with the tip orifice thus we took a
closer look onto the tip of the tip on
this picture you can see the orifice of
an Eppendorf
10 microliters they're not tip it was
just placed under a microscope with the
orifice facing towards the ocular the
tip was a good has a good geometry and
no visible production errors the tips
failing the calibration showed an
impaired geometry of the orifice by
production flaws for explaining most
important production failures I picked
the following two examples this
this example shows the flesh on the
exterior wall around here this slash
built gaps and grooves the liquid can be
retained during the dispensing and left
over from the production a so called
molding flesh is left within the tip
this does not only decreases the liquid
volume it also poses a risk of becoming
ejected into the sample during
dispensing this example shows a
noticeable core shift if the walls of a
piper tip have a variety eMeter the
water may be deflected to the side of
the thinner wall to speak in pictures
the drop jumps to the outer wall and
thus is not part of the dispensing
volume anymore yes I'm talking about
small drops and liquid remainders here
but since we are talking about very
small volume this already counts in
general you can say that the smaller the
volume the more important the perfect
geometry of the tip orifice becomes the
geometry of the tip orifice is fully
influenced by the production quality
keep in mind that a production site for
piper tips produces billions of tips per
year thus a high maintenance frequency
of the tools as well as several quality
control steps are essential in order to
prevent those examples that we have just
seen another important factor for the
system's accuracy is a tip set this
influencing factor is always important
regardless of the volume the tip fit
defines if the system becomes airtight
or is leaking it's lightly leaking tip
option space undiscovered because of
leakage of liquid does not develop
immediately after expiration with tips
having a variety lling quality it
becomes impossible to work reproducible
but one
after the other here comes the
background the tips it is mainly
influenced by three characteristics
position of the ceiling rim quality of
the ceiling rim and production
tolerances more positives are equipped
with the feeding room the ceiling room
is a plastic rim that has the function
to see you the system airtight this
ceiling rim needs to be positioned
within the tip that it becomes pushed
onto the pipette count during the tip
attachment if the ceiling room has a
variety to tip quality the
reproducibility of the pipette eggs
become affected some tips see you
tightly on the cone while others evoke
leakage in order to visualize this
situation a testing plot was with exact
diameter was placed into three tips of
one box of manufacturer G we found the
testing plot to stop at different
positions showing Brian diameter of the
sealing room our production size sites
produce according to a certain
production tolerance such tolerances are
needed in order to evaluate freshly
manufactured products are they okay and
can be sold or are they not okay and
cannot be solved system providers for
example Eppendorf synchronize the
production tolerances of chips and piped
code even if the production tolerances
are maxed out the tip still does fit
onto the pipe it code this is a service
and non system provider cannot offer and
this finding brings us to enough - and
another important fact manual
manufacturers of pipetting tips do not
only sell pipettes and tips they also
sell the assurance that the components
of the system are made in a design and
quality enabling the system to perform
within specified error tolerances
regardless of the tip batch this is
based on a requirement of the isolate
655 generic tip
manufacturers do not have to prove that
the performance of the system is within
the error limits not they are free in
defining production tolerances please
keep in mind the fact that the tip fits
onto a pipette cone does not say
anything about the tightness or the
performance of the system compared with
the coffee machine the best coffee
machine does not deliver best coffee if
you choose cool coffee peps next I would
like to give you one last example before
deducing recommendations can you
remember the calibration protocols I
showed you at the beginning of this
webinar the system was working correctly
with F and off tips but it exceeded the
allowed Arab limits for the inaccuracy
when using the alternative tips
well this calibration was performed
using one tip for all 10 measurements of
the calibration in other words the tip
was reused 10 times in contrast the ISO
at 6:55 recommends to use a new tip for
each individual measurement so let's say
we repeat the calibration according to
the ISO at 6:55 recommendation now we
use a new tip for each measurement
instead of one tip for the complete
calibration now please share your
opinion within a quick poll what do you
think that the calibration result
improves if 10 tips are used for the
calibration instead of one tip
okay thank you for giving me the results
so roughly 60% say that the result will
approve if ten tips are used for the
calibration instead of one - instead 40%
say no it will not be proved now of
course I did this calibration and we
should have a look what was a result so
when using a new tip for each
measurement the limit for inaccuracy and
the imposition was exceeded the random
error describes the random error or
imposition describes deviation which are
not systematically or with other words
deviation which occur with changing
volumes like by the user by temperatures
or temperature changes or variety
quality knowing this guess what happens
if person a type of a reaction setup
with tip change on the next day person B
works on the same analysis but without
change so you will probably get
different results then so obviously with
this manufacturer we have the fact or we
have to face the fact that the tip
change leads to rhythm in position which
you can see here so there are tips like
eppendorf tubes where it does not matter
if you perform a tip change or reuse one
tip with it within the pipetting serious
just clarify by calibration if there is
an influence
after have gone through all these sex I
would like to give you some
recommendations for you daily work first
of all well if possible use pipe at the
tips from the same manufacturer if you
have to use alternative tips you should
check the system performance as
recommended by the ISO at 6:55 with a
2-step calibration first perform a
conformity testing by calibrating the
system using pipette and tips from the
same manufacturer this is to make sure
that the original system is performing
correctly then secondly repeat the
calibration using the alternative tips
please use one tip for measurement for
this calibration in order to uncover
quality related issues you might have to
adjust the pipette if you have to do so
make a remark on the pilot that it has
been adjusted for the use of these tips
repeat the calibration or at least
perform a quality testing with every new
batch of alternative tips if you have to
make a purchasing decision towards
alternative tips please check out the
following take the position of the
sealing ring does it fit onto the
pipette cone is the tip size or the tip
shape shape clearly different from the
original tip when using multi-channel
pipettes roll the tips over the table do
they wobble or do they look bent during
aspiration watch the liquid surface is
it calm or being disturbed aspirate
liquid very fast does the liquid surface
break up and flesh into the pipette cone
check the orifice under the microscope
for production failures or warships ask
your tip supplier to certify that the
tip is suitable for your pipette
calibrate the system with and without
tip change are the results different ask
your tip supplier for
polity control steps within production
and ask your tip supplier if the tips
are free of leachable disturbing
biological assays from more information
about this topic I would like to I like
to ask you to refer to the website
because we have a leachable webinar on
demand if you look through the
literature only very few publications
please define the pipette and by the
tips used this is due to the common
understanding the titles and tips are
general lept rules with minor influence
on the analysis results however as shown
here this is only true for pipettes and
tips of one manufacturer in case of
utilizing alternative tips the systems
performance may be impaired comparable
to the findings with leachable that can
affect study results in fact the results
may not be reproducible when using a
different pipetting system thus we
recommend to state the private and tips
which are used so up to now within this
webinar we have gone through four
important influencing sectors on
pipetting results first of all the tip
design secondly quality of the tip
orifice then we have discussed the tip
fit which influence which is influenced
by the sealing room and finally the tip
change or no tip change so it's a
methodical influence there are much more
influencing factors existing but being
less important but I would call these
ones the big four however you can break
them down into two categories design or
shape related influencing factors and
quality related influencing factors in
general tip related influencing factors
are like an iceberg
you can see only 20% with a bare eye
tips falling off the cup are one example
the other 80% stay undetected if the
system does not become calibrated an
example if the design research related
influence on air cutter size so if using
alternative tips keep in mind that it is
impossible to conclude from tip fit to
the systems performance summarizing the
content of today's webinar I would like
to point out four effects we have seen
that piper tips can impair pipetting
results regardless of the pipe it used
this might be surprising since positives
are single-use items the ISO at 6:55
standard regards the pipe at a tip to be
a system accordingly system
manufacturers produce all parts of the
system to fit to each other this ensures
best performance furthermore by the
manufacturer pipers become adjusted to a
certain tip design if you need to use
alternative tips we strongly recommend
to calibrate the system in documentation
and publications the use liquid handling
system should be named and finally
always choose your tips with the same
care if you choose your pipette so with
this picture I would like to finish the
webinar if you wish to go into further
details please feel free to download the
application note 354 from the event of
website now I'm handling handing over
too soon and I'm very curious for your
questions well thank you so much
Catherine after that presentation was
really wonderful before we get started
on this question and answer session I'd
like to remind the audience and how to
submit questions you could submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking
the green Q&A button at the lower left
presentation window will try to answer
as many questions as we can today so the
first question that we have mm-hmm the
participant asked I'm not using the
original pipette tips what do I have to
do in detail to make sure that the
system is performing well yes thanks for
this question let this answer to be a
little bit longer since you asked for
the details first of all you should
define the accuracy and requirement of
your pipette if you are using it only
for aspirating supernatant there might
be no requirements in terms of in
accuracy and precision in contrast if
you are using the pipette for quality
defining steps you should define the
performance of the system we recommend
doing this according to iso at 6:55 in
the first step you do a performance
testing using the original tips this is
a full calibration with ten measurements
each app three volumes first the nominal
volume then the 50% of nominal volume
and 10% of the nominal volume on our
website we offer and standard operating
procedure for further instructions on
how to calibrate the system of Eppendorf
fibers and tips if the system is working
within the menu sector error limit for
inaccuracy and imprecision you proceed
to step two you repeat the calibration
utilizing the alternative tips please
make sure that you use the new tip for
each individual measurements you can now
receive three possible results first the
system is within the error limits then
the system can be used right away second
the systematic error or inaccuracy is
exceeded in this case you need to adjust
the Pipers to the alternative tips
do not forget to make a mark on the pipe
that it has been adjusted to the
alternative tips third the random error
also called the imprecision exceeds the
error limit in this random error sorry
in this case I would not recommend using
these tips pipers cannot be adjusted to
the random error because it is based on
the right deviation of results within
the setup this is a clear indicator for
variety protic Walla tee furthermore if
you use alternative tips we recommend
calibrating the system with each new
batch of tips so I hope this answers
your question more in detail and that
was great thank you and next one
participant says I have two articles my
church do I have to expect impact on the
accuracy and precision of versus the
answer is yes we have shown within the
study that the performance of some tips
was influenced by autoclaving what you
can do to find out is performing the
calibration according to the ISO a 655
is just this explained so first check
the system using the original tips and
then repeat the calibration with the
outer placed alternative tips right
thank you
and then if tips have such great
influence on pipetting results why don't
we sell a quality system well this is an
interesting question thankful that we
want to give the customer all
possibilities so all tips on the market
are poor or not suitable so there are
good tips on the market that without any
discussion however if you decide for
other tips it is up to you to make sure
that the system performs well and you
can do this by checking the tips and
calibrate the system okay thank you very
much for that book oh okay
next we have a question from Arden what
is the acceptable calibration frequency
for autumn a typist
what what this one wasn't a question
again can you repeat the question please
okay um I'm sorry there are questions I
have a different question now the
participant says I have read the SAP
pipetting liquids of different
temperatures can greatly influence
pipetting accuracy what is your
recommendation for when aspirating low
volumes of cold liquids okay thank you
so this is the general topic we have to
address in the lab so that has nothing
to do with a with the tip itself there
we have to think of a yeah in a
different ways because we here we I
would call it a problematic liquid
actually so that the temperature also is
an influencing factor on the pipetting
results it is an influencing factor
actually on the air Cashel sighs so what
you can do is opportunity one would be
to cool everything down and but this is
something you will probably not like to
do because you need to cool down the lab
and the whole system so the tips the
pipe of the lab and the liquid and you
don't want to use that or to do that so
the other recommendation we can give
would be to use a positive displacement
principle so that way of the air Cashen
principle to the positive displacement
principle so there are devices which can
be used and there with these devices the
piston is within the tip and the liquid
will come into contact with the piston
and then you do not have the air caches
generally speaking this is the cold
temperature and liquids is not only a
problem for small volumes but for all
volumes actually so that's a general
recommendation fantastic
okay well leave some time for more
questions to come in it you want to look
at them
hang on yeah okay there next we have a
question from in Toronto who asked if
the calibration is performed with low
retention tips how made the data change
yeah okay so in general so low retention
tips are tipped with asbestos special
surface so the surface is modified on a
molecular level so there's no additive
on it but it's modified on the molecular
level and this leads to the fact that it
is ultra hydrophobic and it was brought
to market because so many users in the
lab were working with detergent
containing liquids and these detergent
containing liquids have the not for life
habits that they stick to the private
tip surface and with these either
hydrophobic surfaces they they will
become ejected in the same way of water
but as I said the surface of ultra
hydrophobic so the question is does that
make any influence on the pipetting
result and to our it's not part of our
study but we made of course some
research on that and we found out that
was a bigger volumes it's no problem but
with a smaller volume it makes a
difference so with small volumes I would
not definitely not work with water
because in a calibration you normally
use water the reason is that the ratio
of serve
to volume if difference in small volume
tips than to bigger volume tips to
summarize that long answer
so with Bidda Bigga volume tips it would
probably not make any difference but
mother's more volume tips i do not
recommend to use low retention tips in
with water that's very informative thank
you okay if there are no more questions
actually there's one more from tvoaqui
who says do you have any recommendations
of how often we should recalibrate once
a year every or every six months yeah
that's a good question
so when talking about tip batches as I
said in the presentation I do recommend
to calibrate every new tip batch when
using alternative tips regarding the
system itself meaning also the pipette
it belongs a little bit to your to your
work
so the ISO standard says that the system
should be calibrated at least once a
year but it doesn't it does also say
that you can amend or make shorter on
higher frequency in order to suit to
your per your network so for example if
you're working or if you use the pipette
or the liquid heading system in a
quality related analysis step you should
probably calibrate a little bit more
often than just once a year I know from
a lot of pharmaceutical
on base or industry base less especially
if custom of working under regulations
or in regulated fields that they do the
calibrations much more often like once a
quarter of a year so everything every
three months for example it belongs a
little bit to the number of users to the
requirements you have in the accuracy of
the of the pilot to the chemicals that
you use or there's a lot of factors that
play a role here so I cannot give a very
clear answer to that so we really have
to estimate looking from the from the
experiments that you do actually very
very informative thank you okay um at
this time I'd like to ask another
question the question is from leanin who
says when I aspirate liquid quickly and
it splashes inside the cone how do you
prevent that okay yeah I have cam across
this problem with some alternative tips
actually so with that tips of tips I
found out that you have to pipe it very
very slowly at the first two to three
millimeters so when the liquid rises in
the tip the first two to three
millimeters you have to be very flow
after that you can be a little bit
faster in general regarding the a good
pipetting technique you should pipe it
slowly anyway but with some I know these
situations for example your you want to
calibrate and you want to pre wet your
private trip before the calibration and
you have to to do this preventing five
times and you want to go into the
calibration so you want to be fast
and yeah then this can happen so always
be very very slow with your pipetting
and moving the operating button hit
advise Thank you very
we don't have any more questions I'd
like to thank dr. Yost again for such a
wonderful presentation or very
informative
do you have any final comments for us
before we go
okay um I would like to thank our
speaker dr. guests as well as our
sponsor at the door for making today's
educational web seminar possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through November of 2016 you
will receive an email from whether it's
alerting me when this webcast is
available for replay we invite you to
forward this announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event thank you so much and we hope
to see you again next time bye bye